hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Moy right now don't be
thrown off by the simplistic nature of
this game and that slightly unsettling
priest standing over there this game is
overwhelmingly positively rated on Steam
it has over 5,000 reviews and a 96%
rating so there must be something good
about this and I'm gonna get to the
bottom of it so I played games like this
before that a pixelated graphic and seem
seem to be very obviously simple but my
prayers go out to poor Julia it's been a
year since her husband has passed she
hasn't been seen all day I imagine she
is grieving do you mind visiting her at
home it's the house to the right as you
leave town okay thank you
ooh hello oh man kid you ain't look so
good need to stay close to mama
otherwise she'll worry that we've run
off oh really are you mama
whoa did you hear about the boy julia
lost her son in the caves shortly after
her husband died poor Julia man I would
never let my boys out of my sight wow
this is a secluded down where no one
gets to do anything how does anything
happen here there's only four homes
hello whoo
sometimes daddy lets us Pat the sheep on
the head they're so soft
bad lovey I think this is the house I'm
looking for ah
the beds are rolled up into the walls
how convenient
there's a picture on the shelf of a wife
husband and a young boy wonder where
they are well that's probably Julia her
now past husband pose that oh okay that
was me okay so Julia isn't in her home
and I don't know hey my uncle and dad
are out chopping wood to keep us warm in
the winter they should be home soon
okay all right you have a fun day then
girl one of these houses must be mine we
second only imagine less I'm the high I
heard there's gold in the Cape but I'm
too scared Anna they say there's a
little boy that haunts you over your
shoulder well really a little boy much
like Julia's lost little boy I'll talk
to the priest again in the second date
when a big man how you doing he doing
small head
it looks like a lovely day outside you
should head out to the farm if you get a
chance spend some time with the animals
yeah that's what that's what normal
people need spend time on the wild Julie
is not home maybe she's out by the farm
if you could find her that would be
appreciated why is it my job
why am I responsible for this Julia I
have no idea okay
fire that's an informative signer hello
hi
alright that's do I get an achievement
for poking all the sheep well that one
was particularly angry okay so none of
these sheep or Julia I've determined
that through careful selection process
door's locked to the barn so I can only
assume that I need to go over yonder way
where I saw something oh hello
hi are you the guy cutting wood my
brother and I were chopping wood when we
heard moans coming from the cave my
brother went in to investigate he should
have been back by now I'm worried can
you check on him there's a lantern
behind you on that stump okay
why didn't your brother take the lantern
you think that would be something
important when he would go into the cave
oh boy hello oh oh hi jeez hey you come
over here
all right did my brother send you
blessing the moans are coming from
further down I'd go in by my sides no
good you should take this knife who
knows you may need it all right thank
you I'm just gonna go in now
all right you have anything else
pertinent to say go ahead I can't see
you all right bye you later oh boy
like I got a choice oh it's gonna be a
maze-like cape who made this cave hi
who's there oh hi whoa I see you hi you
wanna fight a farmer approaches why do
you have blood on your overalls why do
you have a knife heard moms what have
you done
why do you have blood I killed the Sheep
why do you have a knife I found it I
heard moans what have you done how to
finish this game what what the hell are
you talking about let them pass or
attack all right I'll let you go yeah
you don't seem suspicious at all okay oh
god oh no I think I done did a mistake
that might have been bad
do you finish this game what is this
some sort of meta thing okay
okay hi oh oh oh oh oh please tell me
I'm in a lot of pain
you came here dan my life my name is
Julia and I want to see my child and
husband in heaven my husband was a minor
in these caves he spent days mining for
gold and then one day he found something
he found a gold nugget I thought we
could retire and be comfortable for the
rest of our lives but he didn't trust me
he buried the gold nugget despite me
then he disappeared everyone in the town
heard about a good fortune they thought
I was rich I was so ashamed to tell the
mountain I couldn't tell them the truth
one day my son wandered into the cave he
wanted to find his daddy he wanted to
make everything better but he never came
out of the cave I went to look for him
but it couldn't find him now it's too
late now I have nobody will you help me
will you help me in my life oh man oh
man oh man what do I do she's probably
gonna die anyway but how did she get
injured in the first place was it that
guy I'm gonna go get help then leave me
you coward spurts blood at me thank you
what is happening here all right okay am
I gonna go to the town and find out that
everybody has been murdered Oh what have
I done
hi hello you're new a farmer approaches
why do you blood on your overalls
Oh a woman's spat what do you have a
knife someone gave it to me
I heard moans what have you done I'm
getting help let me see what will happen
to you what at least where the story
shall end at least for now it is up to
the next player this game to choose your
fate just as you chose for the previous
player what what you will be emailed
about your fate thank you for playing
what oh my god I had no idea
haha oh that's so cool I had no idea I
had I had so many ideas how that game
was gonna end I did not think that was
gonna be it what the [ __ ] oh man oh man
that was so cool it's an endless loop it
doesn't matter what you do that's not
what the games about holy [ __ ] oh man
okay I'm not freaking out about that
that is really cool this game is free on
Steam if you guys want to try it for
yourself I highly recommend it but now I
guess the twist has been spoiled but you
still get to determine the fate of
everyone who comes before you so anyway
check it out I'll put a link in the
description below so thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye